this podcast is brought to you by on it
go to honor.com and look at the great
selection of supplements if you find
something you like
pressing code joey and get 10 off
delivered right to your house what's
happening you bad [__] it's
wednesday the 7th of september the joint
is brought to you by
draftkings listen
the first sunday of the nfl season is
here draftking sportsbook an official
sports betting partner of the nfl is
giving new customers i can't miss offer
to celebrate the return of nfl season
tomorrow night we got buffalo at la
right now new customers can bet by
dollars and get 203 bets instantly and
as an added bonus for week one everyone
can experience the draftkings early win
promotion it's simple bet on any nfl
team to win if your team leads by 10 at
any point during the game you get paid
instantly even if your team loses i'm
looking at indianapolis i'm looking at
[__]
uh who else was i looking at this week
i'm looking at miami i'm looking at a
car i don't think indianapolis is even
[__] playing but who the [__] gives a
[__] it's time for you to play and make
some guidance plus we got ufc
saturday with some tremendous fights
diaz check him off whatever his [__]
name is but anyway download the
draftking sportsbook app today
use promo code joey and get 200 and free
bets instantly when you place a five
dollar bet on any football game this
sunday that's co joey only at draftking
sportsbook the official sports betting
partner of the nfl
minimum age and eligibility restrictions
apply see show notes for details
draftkings it's time to win some [__]
getus
the joint is brought to you by freeze
pipe listen
no matter how hot it gets
keep your bung [__] ice cold just
freeze it pack it and rip that
[__] and wait for the hot smoke
to pack through the frozen part
cooling down the smoke as you inhale it
i [__] love the freeze pipe i love
these pieces
whether it's the pipe the big [__]
bong or the bubbler you're gonna lose
your [__] mind freeze pipe is
non-toxic freezes faster than water and
stays frozen longer
freeze pipe cools down the smoke by
hundreds
of degrees your uncle joey's taking care
of you i'm gonna not take care of us go
to freezepipe.com
pressing code joey to save ten percent
on your first order whether it's the new
bong the pipe or the bubbler we're
taking care of you that's the freeze
pipe t-h-e freezepipe.com
pressing code joey and saved 10
[__] percent freeze pipe like a
snowball and the bong
all right let's get this party started
it's wednesday we got a lot to talk
about [__] lickers
welcome to uncle joy's joy
[Music]
what's happening you bad [__]
it's wednesday the 7th of [__]
september it's a great week it's been a
great week so far kids are back in
[__] school
which listen
i'm happy like if i'd be depressed if
she was depressed about school like i'd
be [__] but she told me like august
8th that i'm ready for [__] school
she was up at [__] 5 30 doing jumping
jacks running around the house she set
her alarm for eight six [__] 15. she
was excited as [__] yeah i went out
there and watched to get on the bus and
[__] 10 kids out there
jumping yelling screaming just [__]
uh
just a great [__] time of the year
you know just to see him go back the
leaves are turning
sports is coming [__] alive we're
going into the final stretch of baseball
we're going into the you know when
you're an old man you watch baseball i
don't watch it a lot but i watch two or
three innings and go what the [__] am i
doing with my life i gotta watch a
documentary on [__] the most hated
man on the internet or some [__] you
know they always got a dick documentary
on [__] netflix i did watch
a good one the other night because i
didn't really know the story when i had
him on the podcast
and uh
it was really interesting it's something
i don't believe in but i was
you know i was interested on how he did
it
it's like a lot of people aren't into
murderers right like you know
but if you read like a biography like
richard ramirez or
the guy that used to [__] kidnap
girls and uh volkswagen
you don't read those books to [__]
become a serial murderer i would read
those books to see how they did it how
the [__] did you do this with women you
know
it's [__] crazy and then i lived in
seattle which was uh you know his
[__]
one uh
stomping ground
but when i lived in snowmass village
that was his real stomping grounds
what's this that guy's name
that [__] kidnapped women with the
volkswagen
the guy did a movie about him it doesn't
really matter
but i wasn't [__] reading those books
because uh i wanted to case out fsu
students and beat them up and i just
read that book to see how the [__] they
did it you ever you ever think about
[__] like you're like man
they caught this guy doing this murder i
mean he just watching the news or
something you're like they caught this
guy doing this murder and he's an
intelligent guy
but
for [__] 100 years
chubby italian guys been throwing people
into holes
[__] rivers and you can't figure it
out nobody can [__] figure it out so
it's like you know the easiest way to
[__] ice somebody is just like if you
watch uh
what's the movie i was watching about a
month ago my daughter the [__] uh
the irishman the irishman there's a
scene towards the end when de niro walks
up with the gun
and just goes to the guy hey jillian
whatever the guy turns around he just
shoots him then they shoot him when he
goes to the floor in the middle of the
street in [__] darkness with two bars
in the corner didn't anybody hear
anything anybody but that's how quick it
happens but that's not
what we're [__] talking about here i
don't i don't want to find out how
people murder people i'm just saying
when you read a book on somebody
you get an idea of what the [__] their
steps were like when i read richard
krasinski's book
you know that guy was a [__] savage
we had
uh the cop that arrested him on the
podcast dominic
you know he made me read a book that he
was a part of and when you read these
books you're like where the [__] were
the witnesses
you know you see a [__] uh a guy who
chokes out george floyd and there's a
thousand people with [__] cameras i'm
just i'm just using a [__] example
guys i'm not being a jerk off
but you know then you hear about uh
sammy the bull killed 20 [__] guys
that means he killed 40 because he cop
to 20. how did he kill 40 [__] people
you know is it interesting no but you're
like how the [__] they did it without
getting caught all those years so it's
kind of interesting but what i'm trying
to
i had that uh ref on
years ago when the podcast first started
maybe the second year in
i had uh tim donna here tim donna he was
a ref that [__] uh
you know
if you watch it on netflix it's really
interesting how he did it when you point
shave
you blow calls against the other team
you know [__] like that he didn't do
that
he just knew the game so much he had so
much inside information about the game
like
he would tell you if you watch a
documentary he'll tell you that he would
just another ref would say to him i have
a problem with uh mo cheeks in
philadelphia he's not a good coach or
whatever
and he would take that information
and win games he went like
i don't know 30 out of 37 [__] out
27 out of 37 games that's 17 net winners
that means if you were to put 100 000 on
those [__] games if you had inside
information you're making a lot of
[__] money right now you know so it's
pretty interesting
how he uh
just how he does it you know there's a
show on tv about dirty jobs
[__] one of the best shows ever one
of the best most
[__] like you just sit there going
holy [__]
i don't want to be a a [__] bee
whatever like a guy that takes honey
from a bee and puts all those things on
and [__] but it's pretty [__]
interesting
to see how the [__] they do it you know
so
when i watched this thing on tim donna
haiti on that whatever his [__] name
was the scary thing was i saw two of my
friends in this [__] documentary the
philly godfather who we had on the
podcast was a great [__] handicapper
and there was another guy who i knew
danny b my buddy that i grew up with
was how i got a hold of tim donna he you
know they're all sports betting guys and
that was the information so it was
pretty [__] interesting
how uh he fixed the games how they
nailed him
they [__] nailed you know guys
it goes back to my kidnapping you want
to tangle the web we weave
when you whatever to deceive you know
he was doing great with it and all of a
sudden there were wiretaps on gambino
soldiers and different mobsters and they
were talking about this [__] wrath
so they went to the nba that's a weird
[__] thing like he didn't get caught
directly he got caught on somebody
else's wiretap
and you know that's how they nailed them
which is you know how you know how what
it takes for that to happen
you know what the chances of that
happening that they catch you on a
wiretap of people talking about you you
know what the [__] chances are slim
and [__] none so it's like
what a [__] tango web you know and
just to see his story at the end like
what what his life is now
his wife left him you know he had
he lost a bunch of money but how he
bounced back he got into real estate you
know he lives in shame he [__] up
but he got his life together and it's so
weird that when you hear about these
people that crash and burn like let's
talk about like uh
the guy from seinfeld that went off at
the laugh factory
kramer like he went off at the laugh
factory
nobody's ever seen or heard from kramer
what community could he have gone to
like whenever and i'm not making fun of
kram i'm just talking to you guys about
adjusting to a mistake
what the [__] do you do like what the
[__] do you do any neighborhood you go
to as african americans they go hey he's
not remembered as the seinfeld guy no
more
he's remembered as the [__] guy
that
went off at the laugh factory about
african-americans and it's so [__]
sad i was telling somebody a story the
other day when you watch goodfella we
watch good fellows in north carolina it
was on netflix and a bunch of the guys
we had a screening room so one night the
guys were watching good fellas i came
down and i'm like [__] i was high i'll
watch it for a little while
and they showed the part
where henry hill
and uh
joe pesci steal a truck this is a true
story guys you're gonna love this thing
they steal a truck and a guy runs in and
goes hey two brothers just stole my
truck
you know
it's a great movie good fellas and when
you get the call
to do a movie like goodfellas
you go into it you know i'm just happy
to be in a martin scorsese movie but
then when you get there and they're like
listen
these are your lines you know
you got to really think twice about
those lines
i've had
one situation where i had really weird
lines in the movie and i told them i'm
not saying that
i'm not saying this word that you want
me to do it's like a racial slur i don't
want and i've said the word a thousand
times before that didn't matter i'm not
racist but it was that it was going to
be on film
it was going to be on film forever and i
was going to be seen and people gonna go
that's the dude that [__] said that
crazy [__] in that movie and trust me
when you go like i went to see uh
the movie with [__] clint eastwood
with all the asians when he was saying
all those asian [__] uh
whatever racist [__] in that movie to
those little [__] moon people
and uh i was sitting there with everyone
saying juan who's filipino you know i
was kind of embarrassed he started
busting out laughing because he's like
me i think hispanic slurs are hysterical
whenever you goof on a spanish guy if
it's creative i'll [__] laugh okay
that's the type of guy i'm not gonna sit
there and say that offended me the
[__] best joke i ever heard was
somebody who offended me saying merry
christmas you're probably in some
tenement in the bronx with 22 spanish
people eating a chicken i [__] love
that [__] i loved when he called me and
left me that message but for some people
they don't have that
kind of you know they got offended or
whatever he wasn't offended i wasn't you
know i was i felt bad i didn't want to
laugh at the movie but when you're in
the movie and you're saying all that
listen it was clint eastwood so he gets
a pass you know what i'm saying
nobody's gonna go up to clint eastwood
20 years from now he'll be dead or go up
to him in a hardware store and go i
didn't like the movie when you did asian
[__] he's gonna go go [__] you you
know clint eastwood's a guy from the
past so
it's funny how when you
when they i saw that goodfellas thing
that damn like
and the guys were laughing when he says
it you know
two black dudes just stole my truck or a
black dude just throw my truck
the story to that is just like him
i forget what his name is good dude the
dude who says that lion believe it or
not is a very good dude he's an old
school stand-up comic i can't think of
his [__] name right now he's a polish
dude
so he read the book like i did
goodfellas right
and he was excited about it i was not a
actor or a comic when goodfellas came
out but trust me when i saw the movie it
broke my [__] heart because i wanted
to be in the [__] movie right
so this guy reads a book like me
sends a letter
to scorsese
saying he loves it
sorry i got a little allergies
and uh he says i want to be part of the
movie
scorsese you know whenever you write a
casting director or movie and explain to
them
why they need to see you like i've re
i've written like
seven different letters to casting
directors like why they need to see me
for this role and i think i got like
three of them but
it's a complete different story he wrote
a casting uh he wrote a letter to
scorsese scorsese called them in
this [__] came in
got up went in his jacket pulled out a
gun and put it on the desk and said i'm
here to do whatever the [__] you want
and scorsese you look at him and said
security and they [__] escorted him
out of the building right
true [__] stories now they're sitting
around
you know maybe a month later
and they go and scorsese is like nah nah
we gotta use somebody to say that line
you know who's crazy enough
to want to come in here and say that
[__] line they're sitting around and
go
what about the guy that came in with the
gun they're like perfect call them up
and they call them up
and he goes down they're like this is
the line you're gonna do a black dude
just stole my truck
and the rest is history he got the line
he busted it out but now he was telling
me once like 15 years ago i saw him at
the improv and i go hey man do people
ever give you [__] about that line
because i've always thought about that
line
oh and it's like he goes ah some people
some people look at me
he goes the worst
is when an african-american person comes
up to him and says i know you
and he goes how do you know me i'm a
stand-up come he goes no no i saw you in
the movie and he's trying to beat like
he'll say no you didn't see me you don't
want to say it and the guy will say i
saw you in goodfellas yeah yeah you were
there and he goes the black people just
stopped when they talked and go yeah we
like that movie and the conversation
just sounds [__] hysterical
i remember one time i got that grandma's
boy
i that the name is the nick swanson
movie
i got a call on the friday i got a call
on the friday i was at this agency for a
while they did not like me a friend of
mine referred me a good time actor
referred me to this agency he goes you
need joey they were putting together
like a spanish division so the lady was
stronger than death she was stronger
than that as an agent
she had danny trejo she had emilio
rivera from sons of anarchy
trejo she had the other guy from sons of
anarchy she was doing great this lady
and she signed me i'm like all excited
but i think we had a conversation one
day and she didn't really like something
i said so
she called me one friday she's like hey
man what are you doing tomorrow
like i'm not doing [__] it's saturday
she goes well adam sandler just called
he's got a movie for you she goes if you
don't want to do it you don't have to do
it
it's just two lines
and i can't repeat the lines to you on
the phone they're so bad
and i was like and there was something
i think don johnson was talking i go her
[__] looks like
something that got hit with a shovel or
something like that it was just a really
off line you know i said that line i
remember going now i feel like that
[__] dude in goodfellas for saying
that line about the chicks [__]
but i was like you know what i say it
all the time then the movie bummed and
nobody saw it they got like the worst
review on rotten apples so i was like
nobody's gonna get the [__]
see me uh you know
say this disgusting [__] line i'll
never forget even don johnson said
something to me while we were shooting
he goes that's that's not a good [__]
lie like what am i gonna do
they're paying me for the day i gotta do
what i gotta do like again
hey guys don't forget to watch sprung i
did watch it people like it yeah it's
pretty cool
people [__] like it i gotta get it
what network is it on
pluto or something you can get it
through amazon or hulu okay yeah yeah
people [__] like it people coming up
and i saw you and sprung
taking this [__] greg garcia
is a bad [__] man greg garcia is
uh
unoriginal when it comes to this [__] he
knows how to put together a show
sometimes you're there with him you're
like what the [__] is greg doing and
he's shooting all this [__] he's like
you can go home now you're like really
that's it and next day you see it you're
like what the [__] greg
he's just a goddamn [__] genius this
guy
but anyway i want to talk to you about
something today you know i always save
all my [__] guys like i save
the time the [__] i don't have is
whatever they took from me when they
told my apartment and i had a bunch of
paperwork and stuff whatever i had in
there but for the most part i saved a
lot of [__] guys
i remember one time somebody told i was
lying i said that i got in fact i'm
gonna get another one pretty soon
because i've been talking to somebody
that their phones are tapped i know
they're tapped because they're under
indictment dear friends of mine what am
i gonna do they called me to ask
questions so but i was talking to a
friend of mine i got arrested for
bookmaking years ago like 10 years ago
he called me for a party uh
like for me to do a benefit in hoboken
or some [__]
and i did it and then
like two months later he got arrested
and like six months later
i got a couple letters and the letters
were from bergen county prosecutor's
office
i was living in studio city why am i
getting a letter from
you know the prosecutor's office in
bergen county because
they hadn't let me know i was on
wiretape
i was on tape every time i spoke to this
guy i was always on tape so i think
after the trial was over after he
pleaded they have to release everything
and they sent me a couple letters and i
remember i said something once on the
rogan podcast and i was headed to do the
rogan podcast and somebody said bring
the letter you're lying about that i
broke the letter and i showed it on the
podcast and i'm like i'm sorry i called
you a lego bro i save everything i try
to [__] save
anything negative so i could put in the
book you know all that type of [__] i
put in the book there was something i
sent to the book
where it was a sheet of paper that my uh
my ex found my ex-girlfriend when we
broke up she had tons of [__] of mine
from like
i don't know two or three years in
seattle
and uh
i don't know before she left the life
she goes i found a bunch of chefs here i
want to give it to you and she gave me
all these boxes two boxes and all these
boxes two [__] boxes and it was just
like
comedy paperwork rules
for seattle comedy competition uh
pictures of us
dancing at a comedy thing it's just
stupid [__]
but i found the letter in there that i
had received i had uh
you know when you call those debt people
you have to call to consolidate like you
have to call them and then they take a
fee out and they call all the credit
card companies and they tell anybody you
owe money to they cut a deal with and
you could uh pay back but in the long
run
it [__] up your credit even worse
supposedly i didn't know this i mean
filing for bankruptcy is one thing but
this is sort of it i'm not sure at the
time it was this so i remember i went
through like one consultation with them
maybe a couple consultations
and then right before i was gonna sign
with them they sent me
an itemized [__] list
of what i owed every credit card
discover diners club american express
visa mastercard it was
guys i must have had eight cards that i
owed money on plus
a [__] loan for a car you know i
forgot to tell you guys i got an acura
when i got divorced
and i couldn't make the [__] payments
on it you know we're all [__] guys
i've never come out here told you i had
a perfect life
but i found this thing the other day
because i was scanning stuff i should
have brought it here i was scanning
stuff for the book they want a bunch of
paperwork like little notes i said i
have all these notes maybe it'll add to
the book because i don't have all these
pictures
when i got this letter
i
was 225 000 in debt
i got divorced i got separated in 91.
the divorce went through in 93.
i owed 210 000
and that was without two attorneys
plus personal loans i had taken out from
dear friends of mine
that had to get paid back
so
i you know i threw numbers up for years
when i found this the other day i showed
my wife i go
take a look at this my wife who's an
accountant was like
joey you were dead
i go i know i was dead and when i got
this consolidation letter i spoke to
somebody in seattle and they were like
don't do it don't do it so i never
signed i never sent her back and i still
had it when she gave me the paperwork i
found it so i was down
and i know i gave figures before on the
church
i was down 210 in credit cards and alone
i was down maybe at the time in 98
no reason to lie or be ashamed i was
down about 8 000 in child support which
[__] me at like 218.
i owe an attorney 40.
i owed another attorney about 15
and i owed two twenty dollar two twenty
thousand dollar markers to two dear
friends of mine that had to get the
money back
they gave me this money out of like a cd
or something they busted for me that so
i wouldn't go to jail to cover attorney
40.
20 each
so that's what like
300 down
i was down
with [__] guys i was down
three
guys
let's give it a fair number
i was down 300
000. i've been stressing 20.
never end the school loan that i had
that did not get [__] waived they
found me and [__] made me pay it
which i had no i had no qualms about
held the money i paid it i was down
when i moved to los angeles and i got to
be honest with you guys listen to the
year 98
what i'm about to tell you do not try
this at home
i i beg you
do not try this at home
when you
i was talking to a uh
a jiu jitsu teacher you know rob
schaefer by the way an update on rob
schaefer rob shafer got disqualified his
first fight
his first role
he was very upset i consoled him i'm
gonna give him a call today he's back
from vegas
he got disqualified because he grabbed
the guy's leg to pull it over and the
guy turned a certain way
so they considered a knee bar and they
disqualified him and what made it worse
was
the guy he was beating up went on to win
the whole thing
so
that's the
review on rob schafer but since we were
talking about rob rob trains and
intrepid in marlborough and i was
talking to the owner there one day steve
and we were talking about my cousin
julio up norton
at anaconda
and my cousin is a great [__] jiu
jitsu guy and i mean he knows
jujitsu like a [__]
and he's had schools
for 25 years
julio rodriguez should be and this
wasn't you know i knew this but this is
what my friend told me uh
rob schaefer's black girlfriend told me
that i didn't know this
he goes julio would have had the best
[__] program in new jersey if
he taught in the daytime if he wouldn't
have had his day job my cousin has a
phenomenal day job phenomenal
great money great benefits [__]
insurance out the ass he can do whatever
the [__] he wants
so all those years he he's like what am
i going to do
teach you just from the daytime at night
what am i going to do so he taught you
jutsu at night
but in the daytime he stuck with his job
my friend steve said the guy is
phenomenal
i don't think his school is bigger
because he never
quit his day job i didn't know that that
was in jiu jitsu and martial arts also
that you got to quit your [__] day
job you know so i i didn't know that
when you're a comedian
when you're in a band
i'm sure i'm not the first guy that did
it i'm sure i'm not the first loser that
did this that's why i'm telling you
don't try this at home kids because it
doesn't work for everybody i don't want
you guys coming back on me going joey i
did it because no i did it because i was
a loser in 1991 i had nothing going on
nothing my wife left me i was i wanted
to be a comic i had no job i had a
[__] two-year-old daughter and
maybe maybe if i was lucky
600 in a bank account
i had credit cards i never touched i had
a good salary
anyway i got into [__] comedy my
world fell apart after that
i had been going to college i don't know
three years at a time
every time you take a school loan out or
you get a pell grant they throw you
another [__] card or at least they
did
30 years ago 25 years ago so every time
they threw me a pell grant i knew if i
knew a thousand dollar visa was coming
and then you got
let's take one step at a time i knew a
thousand dollar limit card was coming or
500 hammock or 500 limit visa or 500
limit mastercard or diners club whatever
the [__] i always knew i was getting
another application for a card
so all those years i have to be honest
here when i was younger honest to god
man
i did not
all those years that i was married and
buying cars and
you know
flipping cars i did not touch a credit
card i did not touch a credit card one
time i took out a loan
a quick uh 2600 loan to help me
pay for a car and then i flipped it and
i paid off the loan that was the loan
that was the straw that broke the
camel's back my wife said for me not
telling her that there was a violation
of our marriage and that's why but it
was other things
i took that loan out i paid it right
back there was no [__] issues you
know
but once my wife left me and i got the
comedy bug
once i decided in 93
that i was gonna [__] go for it i
took all those credit cards guys
and i maxed them out on purpose
i'm an artist you know i'm an artist
you know i was not gonna get a [__]
day job you know i didn't not want to
get a day job and i was an artist at
that time i didn't consider myself an
artist i still don't i'm just
bullshitting you [__]
but that's what i did guys you know i
stopped [__] not paying rent i
stopped living like an [__] and i
just used my cards and the excuse was
that i would make it and pay it all back
that's
that's and guys i'm not talking about 60
grand
i'm not talking about borrowing uh
20 grand from grandma i'm talking about
300 [__] large
okay it got to the point guys where i
couldn't go anywhere
guys i couldn't go anywhere i could not
have a phone
they would get my phone and call me
there was no
real uh whatever 95 i didn't i didn't
have a [__] uh call i didn't have a
cell phone to 2004. my point is that
anytime i would have a house like that's
why i didn't have a house phone in
boulder in 93
because by 90
by the time i went to [__] new jersey
they were calling me at different comedy
clubs
guys you know what it's like to get to a
restaurant to do comedy and your phone
rings and the guy's like hey you have a
phone and you're like oh hi this is matt
from discover card you're like what the
[__]
yeah i never got your check oh man i'm
sorry i've been busy i'm about to do
comedy can i call you tomorrow i mean
that's how bad i got they were calling
me at my friend's houses
they were calling me at my friend's
house like if i put somebody down for a
reference my friends would call me a dog
i just got three calls from [__]
mastercard it was horrible
so
there was nothing i could do the cards
were stuck i did everything i could i
kept
borrowing from peter to pay paul like i
was just i would use the mastercard
first
get rid of that [__] the visa
burn that bridge
the [__] uh diners club i went out to
dinner everything every [__] every
meal i could eat i don't even know if
diners club is still around i owe dinos
club about 7 000 [__] dollars
because then i became when i was doing
all that i became the master of limits
i can [__] with you i'll get your limit
up if you got a 500 credit card email me
i know how to get your limit up very
easy go to a casino
that's what i used to do to get my limit
up i would drive to colorado just opened
up all those casinos in 94.95
i would drive to the casinos
gamble and then tell the guy
i didn't know what i was doing i would
go lose like three hands of cards i
don't play [__] cards i don't even
know how to play blackjack people get
mad at me you shouldn't take that card
you you don't hit on 18. you know i
would always do stupid [__]
but i i had no [__] idea what up but
i would go up to those clubs and i would
lose three hands and then ask the
pitbull
dog the pit boss i'd ask him listen i
got 300 on this visa card i want a
gamble and they go let's call visa and
they would call visa together and i
would bump my limit
and then i would i would bump my i had a
different person dying in my family once
a month
they love to pay for [__] funeral
trips home
oh they'll love it this is all inside
information i'm giving you uncle joey's
inside information on how to [__] bees
in the ass
all of them all i would call them up
from a casino and have the pit ball that
this does not work anymore american
express cards i was getting cash
advances on them go ahead try to get a
cash advance on american express i'll
wait you can't
i figured out a way how to do it with
casino money at the casino they want you
to [__] gamble and the visa people
want your [__] gamble how crazy is
that try it next time you have like a 59
limit i know you're not a degenerate
gambler but just try it to see if i'm
[__] lying to you go to a casino step
foot in the casino
call them from the [__] casino let
them hear the bells bing bing bing a
couple old ladies winning and [__] watch
what they say to you on the phone i'm
here at a casino
i'm here with my family i want to go to
a big dinner talk about anything but
gambling but mention casino 10 times
and watch how quick they'll go they'll
go hold on let me check your file
okay what a surprise we'll bump you up
500 limit when you do that to three
cards that's 1500 i'm rocking with so i
was doing that the guys come on you're
talking to the wrong [__] guy but
anyway how did i get rid of that debt
you guys got to remember
when you say to me how do you get rid of
that debt
in 1996 i made 8 600 one year that was
my whole year
95 don't even worry about it i had to be
in the same neighborhood
97 i made 90
200 dollars okay
that was the extent of it guys
so
how do you look at your monthly
like there was not eight thousand
dollars a month there was no four
thousand dollars a month
i'm talking about 800 that's below
poverty that's welfare type [__] i never
went for welfare i didn't need to i kept
[__] doing what i was doing
what i did was this this is the perfect
way to [__] do it i disappeared
i didn't answer the phone i disconnected
all phones i pulled all wires out
i got rid of all credit cards so they
couldn't monitor me
when you have no credit cards they can't
monitor you know all i got to do is
where's my cat if i'm slick i call a
credit card company and go where's the
last where's the last place i use my car
and they'll tell you
you know they'll ask you a bunch of
quiet i can't call them sam michael
klein
i want to know where i lost my card
they'll ask me for my soul show and all
that [__]
but they can't monitor you so i was off
the ra i was off the grid
they never little by little i was
getting letters like how they would when
i was living in colorado i had a p.o box
and i would get letters on how they did
uh they just washed the debt
they just
i would get one like letter every six
months discover got rid of the debt
this one this one this one but guys it
took you got to remember i did all this
in
1995. by 95 i had no credit cards the
debt was official by the time i got in
that car
july 1st of 1995
that's what i was down 310 000
no [__] possibilities when you're
down 310 000 the only way to pay is by
getting
10 40 000 payments you're not gonna
knock it down with 50 bucks a month i
knew that i would be dead
so when they knocked all that stuff down
i got eliminated 210 000
i never paid a dime at 210 000 knock on
wood am i not i'm not proud of that but
that's the way the ball bounces
sometimes especially when you're young
and you're stupid you know i don't know
what they do with you today if they'll
make you pay it i was always prepared
to make some sort of payment
when things started rolling
so i was down
a hundred thousand
i owed two attorneys 55 000
and i owed my friends 40 000 which is 20
which puts me at 95 000
forget about child support child support
had to be up to [__] 15 000 at that
time
so i didn't pay any of those things off
the first time i made any substantial
money
was when i booked that taco bell
commercial
and i called my friends the two i owed
the 22
and i said every week i'm going to send
you 500 500 500 500
and we're going to start working on this
you know because i didn't make a payment
for about two years
i kept in touch with them i called them
and told the truth and they were like as
long as you talk to us if i'd say august
1st and i didn't have the money for them
august 1st i'd call them and go dog i
just don't have it and they told me
themselves they go we don't want you to
send us hundreds
like don't send us hundreds
because you're never gonna make a dent
in it
just send chunks so when i got that
[__] taco bell commercial i started
paying off my personal debts
i paid off the taco bell commercial let
me pay both friends
forty thousand i paid that off
and i think i knocked the attorney down
to one attorney to like five and the one
attorney to like 45.
so at least they were in the game you
know
when i paid my buddies off they [__]
cried
they were like we thought we were never
gonna get this money
and we're still friends today over there
we're still dear friends today
one of them was from mississippi i was
going to see him last week but he was in
la
and the other guy still lives in
colorado they were just they they did me
right until this day
you know i try to call them and contact
them and say hello thank you for that
forty thousand dollars because i would
have never [__] made it
i got the one attorney down to
five thousand the cokehead
and then he disappeared
i kept calling him he changed his number
we did speak and he goes thank you for
sending me the money i'm gonna go to
hawaii or something i never heard back
from i got the money from him if he ever
wants it was like five thousand i think
i had him down to 4 500 because i was
sending all those people
payments the other attorney took a
[__] while
but i since i had no other debt with the
other people i told the attorney i would
start making monthly payments
so at first i was hitting him with 150 a
week he wasn't happy but i was
consistent
150 a week is 600 a month when you owe
you know 15 000 40 000
it's going to take a while and then
something happened in 2004
i got the longest yard
because i knew
listen yeah you could pay off bills
if you don't use that card you keep
sending them 50 and you'll get it down
okay
at the time i was always struggling
so i was paying child support at that
time trying to get back on that and then
my child support
i got a letter when they say that was 60
and that's when me and my wife flipped
because my wife and i at the time were
missing meals
so i could pay child support
so my wife went over to the check
cashing place where i used to cash my
checks because i have a bank account but
i would also get my [__] uh
money orders there to pay child support
so she had him type up the report and
sent it to him then my child support got
knocked down forty thousand at twenty
guys you have no [__] idea what i
went through with this debt then the
barry seiko that was the last attorney i
paid
i started paying him back in 2004 and by
the end of the longest yard
he was paid off
so by 2005 i was completely paid off
to all the people i owed money to took
me seven [__] years
so it was a hundred thousand dollars
plus plus 150 altogether maybe 140
after all said and done and then i had
to get my life started
couch chair bed tv blender you know
yeah little things that people have when
they're 20.
yeah i didn't have to i was [__]
don't get me started on the mustard
that's my weak [__] point i still get
mad at my ex-wife for taking the mustard
when she left me who takes the [__]
mustard guys
but that is a [__] guys i don't
[__] that's why now
i get rid of everything like i don't
that's how me and i became friends i
borrowed 20 bucks from mari i told him i
would have it two days later and i paid
him two days later and he was like i'm
never gonna say this 200 again when i
paid him i go dog i don't [__] my
friends out of money i don't because
i've been [__] out of money if you're
a scumbag drug dealer you go suck my
dick i ain't gonna pay you [__]
but if you're the [__] real deal we feel
you get it that is something that's in
your mind at first
it had me [__] down because if you
know anything about me
i'm paying that [__] like i was
i was
ready to pay that 300 000 credit card
debt like i was like i just have to chop
it up to the rest of my life i don't
like owing money that's uh
and i've trust me i beat a lot of people
for drug money but when you give me
money out of your pocket i understand
and i paid
everything off when
now in like 2000 after i paid the
longest shot off i did get a nickel
credit card
somebody sent me some poor bass to send
me a mastercard but my limit my [__]
interest rate was 18
so if i spent 300 at the end of the
month i'd be overextended on my [__]
18 interest it was a [__] nightmare
when we canceled that card we were so
[__] happy but here's the funny thing
i paid everything like a [__] man i
[__] did it and i wasn't happy about
it while i was writing those checks i
always got dizzy
you know i always knew i could use more
money for cocaine you know what i'm
saying there's nothing like when you get
a bunch of checks and you're like okay i
got this money hanging out i'm paying
everybody but i'm only saving 100 for
coke that doesn't sound right i need
like 250 for an 8-ball but you know what
guys i [__] did it man
and that is something that's in your
mind
don't let it get you down
somebody gave me this advice when i went
to the night when i borrowed the 20 000
one of my friend he goes because i went
in for like 60.
and he was like i'll give you 20 and
i'll tell you why
there ain't no dentist prison
there ain't a debt is prison guys
you know i'm sitting here telling you
this story because you're young a lot of
years a young you're going to fall into
this credit card hole believe me
it's a trap it's always there what's
that just pay your taxes just pay your
taxes too that's a complete debt with
taxes i don't [__] around with them all
right and i owe taxes too
[Music]
because i didn't pay taxes
from 1991
to 2002.
is that the 600 and some dollars a month
no i didn't pay taxes from the guys
after you're in debt and nobody likes
you what are you gonna pay taxes for
nobody like me what am i gonna pay taxes
for
i didn't pay [__] and then my wife today
talked me into going to the irs like a
man
and i was scared [__] and they charge me
150 a month for three years
they're not looking to throw you in jail
either guys they're looking to cut a
deal with you they're looking for you to
have a life when i went to the irs i
thought it was gonna be uptight [__]
people with pencil holders and [__] not
at all i had a lady who was sweeter than
pie
they go back seven years they break it
up and you make payments and when you're
finished you're done
that's it guys just and it was a hundred
and fifty dollars
that's
that's not that bad and i didn't get
thrown in jail
you know which was the [__] scary
thing is getting [__] thrown in jail
so
you know when you're getting debt bro i
lost sleepover i still remember the
first time i couldn't make a credit card
payment how bad i felt like i cried in
the car like i was like
i'm a [__] family but then at this
point listen i went to jail i [__] and
quit high school i had nothing going on
my wife dumped me what am i gonna do who
gives a [__] spend me marry eat
i just said
that this is
what i'm gonna do and either
guys i had a very [__] ugly plan
my plan was to go to la and the first
time i had a problem
somebody accused me of something [__]
hitting them more stealing or something
i was gonna go back kill my ex-wife and
then drive to new jersey and have the
feds hunt me down in north bergen good
luck and i was gonna sell coke or do
whatever stupidity i was gonna do until
i died got shot i got thrown in jail
that was my
that was my outlook at 30 years old when
i got into [__] comedy and when i got
that lamb like i can't believe i'm i'm
in l.a but if something fails [__] it
i'll stop in colorado stab a few people
go to jersey and sell coke until the
cops kill me i kill myself or you know
whatever the plan didn't work out that
way thank god thank god i ended up
and all this happened because i met this
woman because if i didn't meet this
woman i had nothing to [__] live for
right like yeah when you're by yourself
who gives a [__] i don't give a [__] if
you know anything about me i can live in
this room
this [__] room and not
be ashamed i've done it before a little
towel on the floor a blankie a pillow a
[__] tv at night you could watch
netflix on your computer think about it
think about what you would do
if you were by yourself but when you
have a family obviously you can't live
in a [__] shed in your backyard
because i could have found a way to live
you know that that was it when you're a
single loser
you're like [__] it if somebody rents me
a closet
i'm good it's mine i could put some
books on the shelves i knew a guy was
slept in a [__] closet he lived in
his buddy's [__] closet you know when
you walk down the stairs those closets
underneath he lived right in there he
was happy as [__] he was spider-man no
he was at the hulk at the at the [__]
man's chinese theta he's one of those
characters that played the hulk and he
lived over at the martel cartel where i
used to get coke and i'd go there at
night and his name was
do what
be real i don't know what the [__] what
who that
who that that's that's what we used to
call him who that who that lived in the
[__] closet [__] ductus
anyway it's a great week
thank you for watching us this week this
is our first week back from labor day
nobody really knew what they were going
on next week we'll have guests and zoom
and live guests and explosions to
whatever the [__] happens
don't forget
tonight i'm at uncle vinnie's tomorrow
uncle vinnie's they're all sold out do
not forget tomorrow night buffalo
against [__] the rams oh [__]
and then this weekend you got [__]
diaz against chasmat you got a great
weekend you got no excuse i got a
thousand things to do i love you
[__] stay black
have a great week and i'll see you
[__] next monday tip top
[__] magoo
all right i want to thank you
[__] another fun-filled week it
was labor day week was a little slow but
we're picking this [__] up next
week the joint is brought to you by
draftkings listen saturdays ufc
279 i think i hope i don't [__] know
but it's there draftking sportsbook an
official sports betting partner unit of
the ufc
will be there also this thursday night
is the beginning of nfl season and right
now new customers can bet five dollars
and get two hundred and free bets and as
an added bonus for week one everybody
can experience the thrill of draftkings
early win promotion if your team is up
by 10 points at any point during the
game you get paid instantly even if your
team [__] drops the ball and loses
who's better than draftkings nobody now
download the draftkings sportsbook app
today right now use promo code joey to
get 203 bets when you place a nickel on
any bet this sunday that's code joey
only a draftking sports book an official
sports betting partner of the nfl also
download the draftkings fantasy app
they're giving away a million dollars in
[__] prizes
now the minimum age requirement and
eligibility restrictions apply
read the show notes for details now go
download the app
and go win some [__] money
christmas is around the corner gobble
gobble the joint is also
[__] brought to you by freeze pipe
listen
this [__] freeze pipe makes some
bungs it'll make your [__] eyebrow
head shoot out of your head
the hit it gives you is [__]
tremendous it's easy to freeze pipe you
just freeze it pack it and when you're
ready rip that [__] the hot
smoke passes through your frozen part
cooling down the smoke as you inhale i
love these i'm a [__] big fan of the
bubbler it's small nobody knows what i'm
doing it comes with a little pipe that
you could take outside
forget about it freeze pipe is non-toxic
freezes faster than water and stays
frozen longer
freeze pipe cools down the smoke by
hundreds of degrees now listen your
uncle joey's taking care of you go take
care of your lungs [__] to
freezepipe.com pressing code joey to
save 10 on your first order look at that
bung it's [__] beautiful get yourself
a new bong a pipe or a bubbler that's
the freezepipe.com
pressing code joey to save 10
freeze pipe it's like [__] smoking a
snowball and letting it melt i want to
thank draftkings i want to thank cbd
lion
but i want to thank you guys for always
having my back i love you have a great
weekend and we'll be back monday morning
tip
top maguire
you